my current position on politics is fetal
I hear people say just turn off the news
I can't it's my job and I'm not gonna
abandon my post but I'm here to tell you
that I think I've found something that
helps and I need to tell you about it
tonight because it affects our
relationship and what it is is I bill
maher and 100% all in on and completely
into ASMR that's right
ASMR which stands for Oh autonomous
sensory meridian response and no it's
not that thing where you jerk off with
the belt around your neck that's it's an
internet phenomenon where people soothe
themselves by watching people whisper
and quietly touch and rub things
ASMR has become so popular it was even
in a Super Bowl ad this year it's all
experienced something I know you're
thinking bill did you hit your head you
are the last guy we'd expect to be into
some crazy social media fad I know but
when all day long I have to see this
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
if I have to look at that in the day I
find it very helpful at night to watch
this
[Applause]
isn't it easier to accept that our
country is falling apart after you see
that guy so starting right now and
perhaps for a little while I will be
needing to do the show like this I know
it's a little weird but it's what I need
to do to be able to keep talking about
drop this and paper
I'm sorry I can't go any other way I've
tried everything hot yoga
scream therapy Adel scissor this is what
works for pee
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you do I'm telling you people - it
really works when you're dealing with
the guy like drop
[Applause]
and he won't release his taxes even
though the law says he shall deuce
[Applause]
and he brags about cramping women by the
[ __ ] because he's a celebrity
[Applause]
they say fascism dad I've been here I
say it already has
I saved Trump to cover a country that
wasn't America we would Bob
[Applause]
so don't be ashamed of ASMR whatever you
have to do take a Harry Potter wand rake
it across a Perry Como record stir wet
mr. wet Robin with a dildo
rub your penis against Donald Trump
[Applause]
whatever it takes because it worked
[Applause]
I hope I don't have to do that too much
I thank you for indulging me and
hopefully I'll be back to normal soon
until then to all of president Trump's
Russo Republican enablers who heard me
say a few minutes ago that I was broken
a little bit dream on
traitors that's not going to happen
[Applause]
you